nobody could like corporal Lawrence
that's not to say that nobody tried or
that he was somehow unfriendly merely
that he was one of those few that seemed
to be wired differently however in the
trenches of World War one
normalcy was at best a relative term and
one that had minimal relation of life
such as it was Lawrence fought listen to
orders and didn't disrupt the other
soldiers and that was all that was
required so what if people felt
increasingly uncomfortable around him in
a place with a flesh rotting off your
bones while he was still alive was the
baseline of concern a little personality
conflict ranked several levels below a
paper cut Lawrence for his part dealt
with it as he always had that is to say
remained totally unaware of the
avoidance the same way a blind man from
birth cannot mourn the memory of color
Cobra Lawrence couldn't be Mona lack of
company he was quiet as he had no one to
talk to and still as he had nothing to
do for long stretches of time the enemy
trench less than a mile away had gone
silent for several days
letting boredom and nervousness sink in
even more than normal
coupled with the unease that seemed to
radiate off of Lawrence like heat waves
the worst part was that there was no
distinct reason to dislike the Corporal
he was a plain man average height
average build blond of voice in action
nobody could recall him raising his
voice in joy or anger he did have the
occasional odd mannerisms
however he tended to stare a beat or two
longer than was acceptable at people
he rarely slept well and bunkmates said
he would mumble in his sleep almost
constantly the content of those
nocturnal ramblings when they could be
understood were often odd and
potentially unsettling one private moved
to another barracks when he heard the
name of his daughter past corporal
Lawrence's lips followed by a bubbling
muffled needle it was strongly theorized
that he was sent over the trench by his
commanders more out of a desire to have
him away than for his minimal combat
skill he and fourteen of his fellows
were sent across the nightmarish discard
wastes of the no-man's land between the
trenches to recon Atena meat wrench and
secure it if possible
many seemed to hope that Lawrence would
have the opportunity to prove his
devotion to his country by making the
ultimate sacrifice for it it was wine he
was gone that three-day gap as men held
their breath waiting for a surprise
volley of shells that someone started
asking questions whereas before it was
almost taboo to speak of corporal
Lawrence since the departure of both him
and his aura rumors seemed to descend
with the passion of the denied nobody
remembered ever talking of home no
sweet-smelling letters came no soggy
dirt streaked letters left he mentioned
his dreams often and great sometimes
with the men over missed foods of
pleasures but never with any real
passion questions started to float among
the even higher levels of command nobody
was able to actually find his station
orders he came in with a squad of
reinforcements transferred from France
but there was no paperwork the rest of
the reinforcement squad had never seen
the man before he had been lumped in
with them the night before the trip
along with the snips and scraps of the
other squads decimated by the Germans
whispers filtered among the grants of
the Corporal being a
and nearly every man who'd shared a bunk
house with him I've gotten trench foot
and the rooms he haunted always seemed
to smell more musty and sickly-sweet
even for the trench the men sent over
the no-man's land with corporal Lawrence
heard and cared for none of this just
another man among many all with death
certificates waiting a stamp that could
fall at any moment they moved faster
though from crater to crater slipping
over slick modded barbed wire the only
thing that seemed to grow in that
blasted waste charging the last spurt
and into the trench they were greeted
not with the harsh bark of German orders
and rifles but a dense close silence
preparing for an ambush the men started
to filter out into the tunnels and holes
of the trench the men already nervous
were not calmed by their investigation
the trenches stank of mould sweat and a
thin under taste of rotten fruit a vile
cloying slime seemed to have pulled in
every dividend crack sticky is glue and
itchy on the flesh in a world where rats
and insects would try to snatch food
from your mouth even as you ate
they saw nothing alive not so much as a
fly an armory lay in chaos munitions
spilled on the ground rifles tossed like
pick-up sticks a mess hall had been
reduced to ruins the tables and chairs
piled in the center of the room charred
and twisted the rations seemingly
stamped into the dirt by many feet and
still nothing alive or dead was found by
the increasingly anxious soldiers
private Dixon found the first body and
managed to cry out before vomiting they
knew it had been a man only because
nothing else of that size could have
been there it lay on the floor of the
barracks the entire floor the flesh of
it had been smeared somehow spread like
butter over the rough dirt floor bones
already looking pitted and rotten stuck
out at random angles like dead trees in
a still swamp the skull rested on one of
the highest bunks facing the doorway ten
gleaming white fingertip bones crammed
into the cracked eye sockets as one man
went to examine it he found the back of
the skull had been crushed open the
rotting sacking sponge of a tongue
stuffed into the otherwise dry cavity
more remains were found each seemingly
more unsettling and strange than the
last a ring of hands in a sandbagged
watch post ten of them fingers
interlaced like a basket the risks
ragged and broken two men in a tunnel
skin leathery and thin as mummies
eye-sockets tearing an empty mouths
locked and possibly wide their clothes
mere rags under an oily black scum the
latrine sent even the hardest back
gagging and shivering overflowing with
excrement and offal gobbets of meat
bobbed a news from the foul sludge the
whole surface dotted with what looked
like thousands of clean slick eyeballs
nerves in tendons fanning out like gold
fish tales
corporal Lawrence was the first to find
the hole the other men loudly debating
the better part of valor and their rapid
withdrawal from the nightmare trench
it was small in a section of fresh
digging the start of a new arm of
trenches projecting closer to enemy
lines no more than four feet across it
seemed to be the accidental uncovering
of a natural chamber the empty blackness
of it defying investigation private
Dixon recovered and blessedly numb from
his previous ordeals saw the Corporal
prod the edge with his boot then
crouched appear in then suddenly slide
in headfirst before the private could do
so much as utter a sound or question the
private was a good soldier and rushed to
the perceived distress of his fellow
when questioned later he could provide a
little illumination as to what happened
over the two minutes corporal Lawrence
spent in all he could see nothing the
light of a torch seemingly doubled up a
few feet into that dense blackness there
were sounds the rustle of movement of a
loose stone or rubble an odd liquid
shifting a dry rustle that made him
think of the insect husks he'd used to
collect in the summer as he shouted for
aid there was a sudden upwelling of a
repulsive stench like a reptile house
gone sour and old and his fellow
soldiers found him retching helplessly
beside the hole when they came around
the turn it was as they rushed to
private Dixon's aid that the hand
emerged from the hole they stopped and
raised rifles as one body roaring from
the owner of that pale trembling hand to
identify himself as they watched another
hand join the first followed by the pale
shivering head of corporal Lawrence he
was streaked and smeared with Atari
black ooze hacking and coughing thinly
as he hauled his body up beside that of
a gasping private as they moved in to
help the men at the corporal vomited up
a heavy streamed of the same repulsive
slime that coated his body in smears and
globs his cold shuddering body already
more of it into his saturated foul
they were hesitant to touch him finally
doing so after the seemingly endless
river of slime stopped pouring from him
he was insensible eyes rolling and wide
body as limp as a boned fish the men
quit the trench with all speed half
dragging the Corporal they ran with no
thought to cover her death of the escape
they crossed in record time falling into
their home trench like so much cold wood
gasping and shivering one man known to
have bludgeoned a German to death with a
brick curled on the floor in a sobbing
heap the commanders moved quickly
isolating the men and trying to calm the
most lucid for a report
what spilled out would have been
immediately dismissed as lies and
hallucination were it not for their
earnest pleading snares of those
reporting command calmed them with
explanations of battle fatigue and
strange gas weapon tests and shared
silent focused stares as the coward men
were ushered out corporal Lawrence had
little to report of his time in the hole
he could or would say little he stated
that he had slipped and fallen into what
may have been some long blocked
underground pool or perhaps a buried
latrine of the sounds and smells
reported by the private he had nothing
to say only that he had struggled for a
short time then managed to get back out
just as the men arrived truly he seemed
none the worse for wear
in fact he seemed at better spirits than
many had remembered ever seeing him
favoring the commander's with a wide
giddy smile as he was dismissed with a
warning not to discuss the event the
Corporal approved a changed man over the
next few days he was more talkative but
quickly had men wishing for his old
unsettling silence
he rambles about the joys of closed
spaces of creation and destruction that
seemed to spring up all around them
about human pleasures miss the
dimensions and ages of which made some
men threaten corporal Lawrence with a
quiet and ignoble death which only
seemed to stretch the near constant
smile in his face even wider private
Dixon one of the corporals bunkmates
respect to a friend that had woken wants
to find the corporal standing over him
in the night his eyes is bright and flat
as silver dollars they found the private
the next day snarl in the barbed wire
his intestines spread nearly ten feet
around him in every direction not one
man from that trench survived the Great
War although a few died in battle a wave
of sickness took the trench
a few days after private Dixon's death a
strange wasting sickness it seemed to
eat the flesh like acid men waking to
find previously healthy flesh eaten down
to the bone boozing and blackened a
sergeant was found in a latrine beset by
a living carpet of rats they refused to
quit the body even when shot and
attacked several men before the body was
recovered relief finally came the bulk
of the men being sent to various
hospitals many wasting away before they
ever reached Abed corporal Lawrence was
remanded to a French mental ward
transferred after several complaints
from the hospital proper where he was
first sent it seemed his behavior hinted
a growing mental imbalance culminating
with an attempted sexual assault of a
nurse which ended with the loss of three
fingers from her right hand and the
vision in her eye
the Corporal would rant quietly to the
other patients whispers about endless
halls pursuits in the dark flesh laid
out like pages of a book it was
dismissed as so much war fatigue even
mrs. behavior grew less violent and more
unsettling he vanished several times
from the ward only to appear several
hours later as if nothing had happened
when pressed he would begin to sing my
Bonnie lies over the sea in an endless
monotone until the doctors left
exacerbated others on the ward Clement
to be transferred from the whispering
madman a stale musty foul MMus seemed to
sit in the air whenever he stayed an
incidence of infection and the strange
consuming sickness that had beset his
home trench seemed to follow him like a
cloud numerous attempts were made to
transfer the man only to be met with
bureaucratic confusion no records were
found of the man
no entry papers commendations or
incidents not even a birth certificate
through it all he sat for hours on end
cross-legged on his bed
occasionally humming tunelessly or
rambling off the names of his ward
paints between short bubbling giggles
corporal lawrence and 18 men vanished
one November night between a 5 minute
nurse rotation at 3:00 in the morning
the room wreaked of rust oil mold and
sweet rot thick black swaths of
crumbling news coated the beds and
several of the walls white patches of it
smearing and eating to the floor of the
men there was no sign at first as they
searched wonder shifted a better side
only to shriek and then a trip across
one of the sunken reeking depressions on
the floor
in a tight perfect spiral or what
appeared to be hundreds of teeth resting
neatly on the floor after counting they
accounted for the total of all the teeth
of every living soul and that Ward but
one the Corporal was never found nor
were the men the incident was swallowed
by the constant barrage of horrors from
the front and forgotten with ease
stories of a cursed trench wandered
across the front lines often squelched
for being bad luck still they came
stories of strange deaths of
disappearing men found days later alive
but broken and twisted beyond
comprehension stories of a strange dark
figure stalking the bomb little towns of
Europe this may be the only known image
of corporal Lawrence ever recorded taken
several days after his return from the
hole in the German trench
[Music]
you
[Music]